[Music]
could things be heating up between
kendall jenner and clipper star blake
griffin everything's like so good right
now the duo was photographed leaving
dinner on wednesday kendall walking
several steps in front of the nba star
as they left craigs in los angeles oh my
god just be cool the 21 year old model
opted for a casual look sporting shorts
and a loose-fitting top while griffin
appeared comfy too in a black graphic
t-shirt and distressed jeans just gonna
keep
doing me like trying to be the best i
can be they reportedly dined with
kendall's bestie haley baldwin and
memphis grizzlies player chandler
parsons all hopping in the same car when
it was time to bounce it's really nice
to have friends that's close in like
this industry now this isn't the first
time kendall and blake have been spotted
out and about they were actually
together the night before too and
earlier in the month they were seen
exiting avenue nightclub in la an
eyewitness says they left in the same
limo around 1am it's really exciting
while the reality star was most recently
linked to rapper asap rocky people
magazine reports that kendall is keeping
her options open adding quote she is
still dating asap rocky as well but she
and blake are hanging out and there's
potential there
keep it true
you